you ready for another bout what you
getting sleepy hey youtubers it's
Charlie so Marvel has so much stuff
going on for comic-con this week I
thought I'd do a preview for all the
movies it's taking to comic-con there's
a bunch of them so I'm gonna be doing a
separate video just for agents of shield
this will just be the movies be sure to
subscribe to get that shield video be
which I wanted to give a big high five
to all the new subscribers thank you so
much for something to my channel I hope
you enjoy all the comic con days I'm
going to do this week I have a ton of
their stuff on the channel be sure to
check it out so the big Marvel Universe
panel is on Saturday just like last year
and just like last year they're going to
show off a bunch of different things but
the two big movies that are going to be
there are captain america the winter
soldier and thor the dark world they'll
definitely be showing off new footage
from each of them obviously Captain
America will be the first footage we've
seen so that'll be just a teaser but
they'll show off another thor trailer 2
which will feature a Christopher
Eccleston's villain character the really
big news though is there going to be
announcing some of those untitled movies
in phase 3 the first one is dr. strange
they pretty much already confirmed that
but the other movie is still unknown
that could be a couple different things
which I'll talk about in just a second
the other big thing is that Edgar Wright
is the director of ant-man he's going to
be there for a different movie World's
End is also really awesome movie should
check out but because he's there and
because Marvel is going to do a big
phase 3 announcement as well as their
current phase two movies they're going
to bring him on stage 2 t's some ant-man
stuff just like the ant-man stuff
they're also going to be teasing some
guardians of the galaxy stuff and even
though they've been shooting and they
want to release a clip the visual
effects process just takes so long to
finish that's why movies spent so long
in post-production that being said
though we will get some images from the
set there are a lot of people including
me that feel like they're also going to
use this panel to do a full phase 3
announcement that is they're going to
talk about every single movie that's
going to be in phase 3 just like you
remember last year's they did that phase
2 announcement where they announced all
the movies that are going to be in phase
2 even if they didn't have footage from
those movies so obviously they're going
to announce Doctor Strange and there
another mystery movie obviously they're
going to be doing Captain America 3 & 4
3 so we can kind of not think about
those too much we want to think mostly
about that unknown movie what is that
other mystery movie going to be well
there are a couple possibilities and
here's where you can jump in and let me
know what you think first of all black
panther and miss marvel those are the
two big things that marvelous talked
about wanting to do and other directors
have talked about like Joss Whedon but
they haven't really made any definitive
statements so expect to hear more about
that at the panel thinking about all
this awesome phase 3 news that they're
going to drop on us during the panel
doesn't really go on to mention anything
about Iron Man so if you remember
earlier in the year there was a bunch of
contract issues with Robert Downey jr.
and Marvel they hadn't locked him down
for any of the Avengers movies after
iron man 3 or any other Iron Man movies
well recently they just re-signed him he
is confirmed for Avengers 2 and Avengers
3 and even though they haven't set a
date for Avengers 3 they already have an
idea of where the story is going to go
so they're just locking him down so once
they get it done they won't have to
worry about him what does that mean that
means that they're not talking about
Iron Man 4 so there is a very good
possibility that there won't be an iron
man movie during phase 3 at all that
makes a lot of sense because if Marvel
is going to have him in Avengers 3 it'll
give them time to find a new Iron Man
and introduce him in the Next Iron Man
movie which could potentially come after
Avengers 3 but let me know in the
comments below are we not going to see
iron man for until after Avengers 3 or
will they announced it during the marvel
panel now for some of the good stuff so
I've got some spoilers for Captain
America the Winter Soldier so if you
don't want to know anything about winter
soldier even the stuff that they talked
about at the panel be sure to turn the
volume down now
so captain america the winter soldier is
all about the idea of the past coming
back to bite you in the ass I know it's
really classic story but each of the
main characters Captain America Black
Widow Nick Fury have someone come out of
the past to make big big problems for
them during the movie obviously a lot of
people that read the comic books know
that the winter soldier is Bucky Barnes
so Sebastian Stan is going to be the
primary protagonist for Chris Evans in
this movie also he has some tie ins with
black widow remember he's basically
brainwashed to become the winter soldier
by the Russians and who's from Russia
well Natasha Romanoff and that's going
to come back and buy both of those
characters in the ass there's also nick
furious character so if you remember
Robert Redford was cast is this really
vague Washington DC character who kind
of lorded over shield he's basically
like Nick Fury's boss in a sense and if
you look at some of the descriptions of
the movie online it talks about a
shadowy figure in Washington DC causing
problems for shield obviously that's
going to be Redford's character you also
find out that read first character is
behind the actions of the crossbones
character in the movie and although we
don't know what crossbones is going to
be doing to cause trouble for the heroes
in the movie we do know that Redford's
character is going to be the person
orchestrating all those actions I'll
talk more Captain America spoilers in a
future video but right now you can
actually check out that shield video I
did think of it as like the most fun
thing that Marvel is doing this year so
get really excited for you can click
here to watch that comic con preview I
talk about some of the stuff they're
going to do on the panel and some of the
other things that they're going to tease
you can also click here to watch some of
my other comic con videos it's going to
be a super awesome week I'm going to be
posting a ton of videos so get really
excited I'm probably not going to sleep
that's okay marathon high fives
you